foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30 off
your order with my code Knowles Canada
wlas that's goodranchers.com use my code
Knowles today the presidential race is
heating up Ron DeSantis is releasing a
southern border immigration plan we'll
get to that in just a little bit first
though
unbelievably Levine is somehow not the
most unpopular prominent politician in
the Biden Administration or should I say
not the most prominent unpopular
politician in the Biden Administration
that honor would go to Kamala Harris and
you don't need to take my word for it
and you don't need to take your hunch
for it we have polling on This from NBC
News Kamala Harris is the least popular
vice president in recent memory the poll
conducted this month shows 32 percent of
registered voters have a positive view
of Kamala Harris compared with 49 who
have a negative view of her this is a
net negative rating for those of you who
are not mathematically inclined of
negative 17 points the lowest for any
vice president in the polls history and
if you compare it with other polls
you're looking at at least the least
popular vice president since 1995
Saint Al Gore and maybe even less
popular
going further back this is of course
very bad news for Kamala Harris really
good news for Biden though and it's not
a coincidence I don't think
Biden picked Kamala Harris because he
said that he was going to pick a black
woman and there were like three options
among prominent politicians and so it
was either her Karen bass who's an
actual communist or Susan Rice who is
the fall man for the Benghazi terror
attack under Barack Obama so not a lot
of options and he picked Kamala Harris
and I think one of the other reasons
that Joe Biden picked Kamala Harris is
because she's deeply deeply unlikable
and this is a factor that goes into
picking a vice presidential candidate is
you want to pick a VP who will not be
more popular than you and who will give
your opponents pause when they're
thinking about impeaching you
so Joe Biden has nothing to fear from
Kamala Harris Kamala obviously wants to
run against Joe in 2024 but she doesn't
have a snowball's chance in hell Pete
butterjudge is another Cabinet member
who wants to run against Joe Biden and
Pete Buda judge also is a complete joke
of a candidate and going nowhere so the
only real challenge that Joe Biden yet
right now is from Gavin Newsom in
California and he is running a shadow
presidential campaign but the Democrat
Party is so rigged and it's so
controlled by party Elites that it would
be very difficult for Gavin to mount
some kind of an Insurrection you're
seeing RFK Jr trying to do that right
now difficult to see how that ultimately
works and so Newsome is just waiting in
the wings to see if Joe Biden you know
God forbid falls down a flight of stairs
or something Gavin Newsom can come in
and take over the mantle but as of now
no serious threat to Joe Biden certainly
not from his vice president Kamala was
just out giving a speech and reminded us
why people don't like her very much here
is her take on pro-life and abortion
advocacy
or deeply held beliefs
to agree the government should not be
telling her what to do with her body
now of course the majority of Americans
do not believe in this this is why it's
a very contentious issue and even for
people who are pro-abortion nobody
really believes this
Christianity has been clear from day one
that abortion is completely unacceptable
the the Catholic church has never
wavered in this position going all the
way back to the DACA the first sort of
proto-catechism of the Catholic Church
you see that abortion is immoral
unacceptable this teaching has been
reaffirmed throughout the ages uh
Christians in order to support legal
abortion Christians do have to abandon
their faith and Pope John Paul II made
this very clear when he said that the
right to life is not just one right
among many you know we've got the right
to life we've got the right to drive a
car we've got the right to own a gun the
right to life is the fundamental right
on which all of the other rights rely
so yes you would have to abandon your
faith and that's what many libs have
done
many pro-abortion people will tell you
yeah I'm not a Christian I'm not I'm not
this religion I'm not that religion yeah
I I am a liberal That's My Religion so
she's wrong about that but put that
aside for a second
politically what's so stupid about this
line is that the principle she's
appealing to appeals to nobody right now
she's appealing to a principle of small
government
she's saying we need to get the
government out of people's lives but
that doesn't appeal to anybody it
doesn't appeal to the Liberals
who are
infamously in favor of bigger and bigger
government but it also no longer really
appeals to the conservatives who for
some recent decades have created an idol
out of small government but they've
moved away from that over the last seven
years
now when you move away from silly things
you want to move towards something good
and I would recommend you move towards
your dinner table where you're serving
up some good ranchers baby right now
head on over to goodranchors.com use
promo code nulls as our great nation's
birthday approach as we are coming
together as proud Americans and savoring
the delicious Taste of homegrown
American made meat our friends at good
Ranchers have the best Quality Meats
you've ever tasted and they only sell
meat that was raised here in the USA
from now until Independence Day good
ranchers will be offering the best deals
to give you freedom from the meat aisle
from rib eyes New York strips
all-natural Burgers the most delicious
chicken you could ever want good
ranchers has something for everyone and
right now you get 30 bucks off with our
code Knowles at goodranchers.com this
meat is the best on the market it's just
absolutely phenomenal I've never seen
anything like it the price is lower than
its competitors and then you're going to
get an additional savings it's unreal I
have people over I want to make sure
it's not just me saying it so I have
friends come over and we and everybody
says the same thing what are you waiting
for let the mouth-watering aroma of
American made meat fill the air bringing
Joy unity and delectable flavors to your
celebrations head on over to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles for 30
bucks off any box promo code Knowles
goodrances.com goodranches.com American
Meat delivered
over the last 50 60 years both parties
have
in different Realms exalted small
government the libs have done so on the
social issues they said get the
government out of my bedroom get the
government out of my social interactions
get the government out of my weird sex
stuff get the government out of my drug
use get the government out of all these
what we call social issues the the
conservatives have done so on the
economic front they've said get the
government out of my business get the
government out of my wallet get the
government out of my bank account okay
both parties are increasingly moving
away from that because there's no such
thing as a small government in a country
of 330 million people
and there's no such thing as a small
government in any society because
we have questions that we have to agree
upon and we have laws that have to be
enforced so even in the earliest days of
the American Republic there might have
been a much smaller federal government
but there was a much bigger local
government the local government had a
lot to say about when you could buy
things there were Sabbath laws the
government had a lot to say about what
kind of weird sex stuff you could engage
in deviant sexual behaviors were illegal
and some were harshly punished the
government had a lot of a lot to say
about what kind of things you could
import and what kind of what kind of
things you could sell the government had
a lot to say about who could live in the
country who could vote who could do this
who could do that so the government was
very very big at that more local
level on social issues and economic
issues and both sides embraced
libertarianism in specific spheres in
the latter part of the 20th century
early 21st century but now both are
moving away from that the the hey just
accept uh be tolerant let us do what we
want to do get out of my bedroom that
kind of liberalism has given way to you
will worship the pride flag or else you
will sit through the pride diversity
inclusion session in your school or
you're going to be punished you'll do it
in your office or you're going to be
fired and on the right
the shrink the government let me spend
my own money kind of libertarianism has
given way to a more robust focus on
rebuilding American manufacturing on
using protective tariffs as a way to
balance out some inequalities in foreign
trade has given way to the government
going in and pummeling big tech
companies when big Tech is censoring
conservatives both sides are favoring a
more active role of government right now
because they recognize that as they've
ceded that power it has benefited their
political opponents in this case it's
benefited the left way more than it's
benefited the right I guess you might
say it's benefited the unit party
establishment against populist movements
on the left and against the right so
Kamala Harris
not preaching to anybody her message is
not resonating at all the other
prominent woman in the Biden
Administration Korean champir the
president's press secretary has come out
and and she's she's articulating the
Biden 2024 campaign message for the
campaign Trail
We Believe Reaganomics doesn't work
we've been very clear we believe that
trickle down
a trickle-down economy doesn't work it
has not worked that is shown to be the
case for decades now and so what we have
been very clear you hear me say this all
the time building any comedy from them
from the middle out and bottom up that's
what we want to do and every piece of
historic legislation speaks to that
speaks to what the president wants to do
very loud and clear in historic fashion
Ronald Reagan died almost 20 years ago
Ronald Reagan has been dead for almost
20 years Ronald Reagan left office 34
years ago
can we shut up about the Reaganomics
already
have does this does this talking point
still work Reaganomics are we going to
start talking about Coolidge cooler
genomics don't work listen James
Garfield and omics are bad for this
country and I recognize that Joe Biden
remembers the election of James Garfield
and Chester Arthur but most people for
most people this is the distant past
okay and it's just the same tired old
lines from Biden and from Kamala Harris
and from Korean Jean Pierre and the
whole liberal establishment maybe that
doesn't matter maybe they've rigged the
elections enough that it really doesn't
matter what the people think but I can't
imagine this is resonating and in fact
it's reflected in the polls because not
only Kamala Harris but Joe Biden were
down in the doldrums in terms of
popularity and then this line that
Kareem Jean-Pierre says she says we
don't want an economy from the top down
the trickle down we want an economy from
the bottom up no you don't you obviously
don't because it was you and the libs
who were pushing all the covid lockdowns
which was the largest transfer of wealth
in human history from the lower classes
to the upper classes from the multitude
of small businesses to the handful of
oligarchic large businesses
that's what you want
who's the party of the Rich would you
say today the deplorable irredeemable
filthy dirty hillbilly bitter clinging
mag Republicans that the the liberal
establishment despises or the
jet-setting John Kerry's Joe Biden's
cutting deals with China and Ukraine
sipping lattes preening and sneering at
the rest of their countrymen who's the
party of the people I don't think this
is fanciful wishful thinking here I
think we can all agree whatever the
Republican party was 10 20 years ago
whatever the Democratic party was 10 20
years ago today
the GOP is the party of the people
and the Democrats are the party of the
elite
who disagrees with that
and they have the audacity to say we're
building an economy from the bottom up
no you're not it's it's the same thing
that you hear from the Democrats when
they say we're the party of democracy
and it's the party that constantly is
chipping away at democracy
the Republicans of the party say hey we
need voter ID hey we need to make sure
that these elections don't get stolen
hey we need to make sure that we have
representation for marginalized people
and it's the Democrats saying no you
don't it's even in the way that the
parties are run the Republican Party
basically has a free and open primary
process the Democrat Party has party
Elites very influential usually very
wealthy people who come in and pick the
nominee through super delegates if
there's any confusion
it just doesn't resonate nobody really
buys this and so the outcome of this is
not necessarily that the people are
finally gonna have their voices heard
and they're going to throw Biden out of
power and they're going to put their
representative in might be the case that
the electoral system is so rigged now
and both parties believe that the
electoral system is rigged according to
polling and if you have eyes and two
brain cells to rub together you could
see that you can see that in the run-up
to the 2020 election when the libs
change all of the election rules to
benefit them and to make it harder to
have any transparency or accountability
of the vote that that constitutes a
rigging you might say well now the
system is just so rigged it's going to
be very very difficult to overcome that
but let there be no confusion about
where things stand
the the the people preening about
Reaganomics and whatever they are very
clearly the party of a small oligarchic
Elite you want to talk about bad
economic policies that are deeply
unpopular with people
New York City now I couldn't believe
this I had to I had to read this
multiple times
to find out it wasn't a joke New York
City
is telling pizza places
that they need to cut their
emissions
by three quarters
or they're going to be put out of
business
now before I get into the story what do
we do we say pizzerias
do we say Pizzeria
do we say pizza like the Italian
pronunciation do we say
it's a places do we say pizza parlor
remember we used to call them pizza
parlors no one really says that I don't
know what do you call a pizza shop pizza
shop I don't know anyway
it's a date Russian it's a it's an
linguistic point for another time New
York City
is telling these Pizzeria that they need
to cut their emissions by three quarters
that's the Department of Environmental
Protection new rules that say that
Wood-Fired good pizza places need to
change the way that they make pizza or
they're going to be shut down by the
city
they're saying that there are harmful
pollutants in neighborhoods with poor
air quality and we need to control
emissions because people are going to
choke on the pollution of a delicious
tasty Pizza I wish that I had the the
emissions from a delicious pizza place
down the street or downstairs from my
apartment how wonderful would that be
that would be the most delightful
fragrance that I could imagine in my
apartment
but instead they're saying that's a very
bad thing and everybody hates the smell
of pizza of course and that's why we're
going to shut down the pizza shops
does anyone really believe does anyone
really believe first of all that the
emissions are going to cause the sun
monster to end the world no
the people who do believe that have
already said it's too late don't forget
Greta thundberg more than five years ago
now came out and said that if we don't
cut off fossil fuels within five years
it will be too late and Humanity will be
wiped out and we've passed that point so
according even to the most prominent
environmental activist in the world it
is too late there is nothing we can do
to stop catastrophic global warming that
will wipe out the human race so the only
reasonable conclusion that one could
draw from that even if one believed the
ridiculous premise is to eat drink and
be merry and specifically to eat tasty
wood-fired pizza
but they're going to keep it up even
though they say they already say it's
too late doesn't matter we've still got
to suffer we've still got to sacrifice
we've still got to give up our pizza and
that's the point
the reason that they're going after your
pizza is not because your pizza is
causing global warming compared to all
of the other pollutants in the world
New York City wood-fired pizza
represents 0.0 of the pollutants they're
going after your pizza specifically
because it will make you suffer
specifically because it is a sacrifice
because sacrifices and suffering are an
important part of religion and
environmentalism represents the
pseudo-religion of the left
and because rule dietary rules rules
around what you're allowed to eat what's
clean what's unclean they make up part
of religion
and because liberalism is a mockery
religion it's a pseudo-religion to
replace the traditional religion of our
civilization which is Christianity
they've got to have all that stuff too
and because societies are defined by
their taboos and taboo is a religious
concept they're going to make the thing
that you really like taboo
a lot of people are curious as to why
the liberal establishment seems so
hell-bent on making us all eat bugs
you're seeing encouragements for us to
eat bugs from institutions like the
world economic Forum from popular
celebrities like Nicole Kidman from
Liberal politicians from social media
influencers on the left why
why do they want to see bugs well they
say these bugs are really
environmentally friendly
and you can grow them anywhere
and they don't they're not going to
cause the sun monster to kill us all
and so despite how gross it seems
you have to eat the bugs but the despite
is what people are misunderstanding here
they're not trying to get you to eat
bugs despite how gross they are they're
trying to get you to eat bugs because of
how gross they are because it will
violate one of your traditional taboos
in your culture and by changing the
taboos that will change your culture and
it will change the entire political
order
there is
nothing that is more New York than pizza
that is what New York is that is
old-timey traditional New York and so if
you are a social and political
revolutionary and you want to change the
culture of New York you're going to go
after the thing that defines it and
Pizza is at the top of that list and so
they're going to come and they're going
to take your pizza you know what I say
I'll Channel my inner Charlton Heston
you can take my pizza from my cold dead
hands
as a New Yorker by birth and by
education
so I think the grease from all that
pizza in my whole life is one of the
reasons that I look so good when you
want to look good at glowing you got to
check out geniusell right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles dehydrated skin
covered in dark spots and even puffier
bags under the eyes it could be a
problem for all of us all right and
thankfully geniusell has the answer
geniusella's extended your chance to get
their most popular package featuring
beautifully curated skincare Essentials
for life outside in the Summer sun Genia
sells limited time summer Essentials
package includes their one-of-a-kind
Ultra retinol super moisturizer with a
powerful plant extract a retinol
alternative that delivers results
without the harsh side effects and is
perfectly safe to use in that summer sun
you will also get geniusell's classic
skin care therapy for under eye bags and
puffiness that will get you compliments
everywhere you go plus with its
immediate effects results guaranteed in
12 hours or less or your money back for
one more week every summer Essentials
package includes their nourishing
vitamin C serum for a visibly clear
complexion love the company love the
founder Coptic Christian from Egypt who
left for the American dream head on over
to geniusell.com Knowles right now get
the summer Essentials package for over
65 off just for the summer every
subscription order includes a customized
Summer Spot gift box absolutely free
geniusell.com knowlesjaysl.com
slash nulls
speaking of pizza
did you know that the body mass index is
racist
BMI
which is one of the ways that we measure
obesity
that is now racist according to the
American Medical Association which is
the largest Council of doctors in the
United States they're going to say
goodbye to it because BMI they say has
racist Roots the report from the AMA
says that quote BMI does not
appropriately represent racial and
ethnic minorities because it's based on
the imagined ideal Caucasian of the 19th
century without considering a person's
gender or ethnicity
so the reason that they're saying it's
racist is because
black women in particular are very obese
as a group they are the most obese group
of anybody this became a political
talking point during covid because
people who were more obese were more
likely to suffer complications from
kovid and so the lib said that covet is
racist but coveted obviously is not
racist there are just certain unhealthy
behaviors and conditions that are more
associated with black people than with
white people and specifically black
women than other people and so they say
it's all racist and it's all because of
white supremacy because everything has
to be white people's fault so the AMA
goes on they say South Asians in
particular have especially high levels
of body fat and are more prone to
developing abdominal obesity than whites
which may account for their very high
risk of type 2 diabetes and
cardiovascular disease in contrast some
Studies have found that blacks have
lower body fat and higher lean muscle
mass than whites at the same BMI and
therefore may be at lower risk of
obesity related diseases notice they
don't compare bmis of the different
groups they're just saying at the same
BMI here's muscle to fat and of course
that's true different peoples are
different obviously I'm a little swarthy
here my ancestors come from Southern
Italy and at least on one side of my
family and so yeah my skin is going to
be a little darker than people from
Scandinavia it's going to be a little
lighter than people from Nigeria my hair
is going to be a little bit different
than the hair of people from all over
the world and so sure it naturally
follows that all sorts of aspects of my
body are going to be different from
other peoples
does that mean that body mass index is
no longer useful
no of course not that's a complete
non-sequitur
does that mean that BMI is racist
no of course not but
racism as we've observed on the show
before and is becoming increasingly
clear in our culture
racist just means White
if a thing is white if a thing has
connection to white people if a thing is
more closely associated with
white people than non-white people it is
racist in our modern culture white just
means bad
so because BMI was developed by white
people
on white people using experiments that
involved white people it's just bad
because America
historically was a white country America
is bad because Europe is the continent
of the white people
then Europe is bad and
those places will be blamed for things
that take place in Asia that take place
in South Asia that take place in Africa
that take place in Pacific Islands
slavery cannibalism even cannibalism
which wasn't actually practiced in the
west and the word comes from the
indigenous peoples of the Americas and
specifically from the Carib Islanders
doesn't matter there'll be anything
anything
that has existed everywhere it's bad
when white people do it it's not bad
when other people do it and that's that
and you can try to make sense of it and
you can bang your head against one say
wait a second this is so crazy these
lips have gone too far how on Earth
could you say that that ways to protect
the health specifically the health of
black people could ever be racist it
doesn't come on the logic it's not
logical you you have to recognize that
the libs are beginning with the
conclusion the conclusion is white
people are bad okay white people are
they're the only group for whom you
against whom you can legally
discriminate and socially discriminate
Asians you can also legally discriminate
against in college admissions and
employment but and really specifically
College admissions affirmative action
but
white people are the only group where
you not only can legally discriminate
against them but it is socially
acceptable and encouraged to insult them
to discriminate against them socially to
ostracize them it's the only group so
that's the conclusion and you're going
to fill in all the the Absurd background
such that you've got the American
Medical Association saying oh obesity is
great obesity is great if you lose
weight you're racist and you see this in
the body positivity movement and the the
now worship of a pop singer like lizzo
if anyone suggests that maybe lizzo
ought to get a little bit more healthy
that that would be good for her that's
considered racist speaking of racial
issues
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis number two
guy in the Republican race for president
has a new border plan
a record 2.76 million migrants cross the
border during the 2022 fiscal year
shattering the previous annual record by
more than one million
to walk but have already traveled
hundreds of miles
along the U.S Mexico border yesterday
that is growing humanitarian crisis at
the southern border pounds
[Music]
everyday Americans less and less safe
there we go we see all the members under
27 terrorists apprehended trying to
cross the border so true
we will secure the borders
[Music]
like that he's using the word Invasion
that's very strong no excuses okay
the plan might be good the commercial's
weak and the commercial's weak because
the commercial doesn't include specifics
and because the commercial is diagnosing
the problem recognizing the problem but
not getting specific on the solutions
other than all the stuff that
Republicans have been talking about for
a long time that they haven't really
done
Trump had a real Advantage here in 2016
because he offered new Solutions
we're going to build the wall we're
going to deport all these people we're
going we're going to end Birthright
citizenship okay great wow that was new
that sounded exciting people voted for
him on that
premise but then he didn't really do it
he built some of the wall
illegal immigration dropped in the first
months of the presidency but then the
illegal immigrants and the cartels
realized that the law wasn't really
going to be enforced maybe that was
Trump's fault maybe it wasn't Trump's
fault maybe Trump just couldn't wield
the bureaucracy effectively enough
regardless
illegal immigration jumped right back up
so
now the the idea of building the wall or
whatever even that is not novel
people need more specifics and and we
need to believe that you can actually
get it done now in his speeches Governor
DeSantis has been more specific and he's
talked about how he intends to wield the
levers of power which is good I mean
that's that's a big Improvement I wish
that that sort of thing were in the
campaign commercial this commercial
doesn't really do anything for me I'd
rather just see DeSantis explaining
Nitty Gritty detail what he's going to
do because nobody really believes that
it's going to get done I don't think
anybody really believes that Trump is
going to get it done I don't think
anybody believes that DeSantis or any of
these other candidates are going to get
it done no matter how much they want to
because the the feeling is that even if
a president is totally sincere about
stopping illegal immigration that the
Deep state is going to is going to cut
them off at the knees
that it's going to be held up in court
that's going to be held up by the
executive agencies and that all that
time the borders are going to remain
open and the illegal immigrants are
going to come over to the tune of three
and a half million per year
you know it's it's not totally fair to
attack DeSantis for this because
the reason that
he needs to get so specific the reason
he doesn't really have credibility here
is in part because even Trump failed to
do it even Trump who is the most
anti-immigration president for
presidential candidate for a major party
in my lifetime even he couldn't get the
job done
so now I wonder if immigration is even
going to be a big issue in 2024 I think
a lot of Republicans have just written
it off just said yeah
we tried there's really no solution on
the horizon we've got to focus our
attention
elsewhere speaking of unwelcome entities
invading our space Here's a disturbing
story from the daily wire A.I teddy
bears could be reading customized
bedtime stories to your kids within five
years this is according to VTech
Holdings which is a has always been a
kind of higher Tech
toy company
Hong kong-based toy and electronics
company they're looking very closely at
the use of AI within toys and they would
equip the toys with a chat GPT style
intelligence they're hoping to do it by
2028 and so what they'll say is you can
incorporate not only the kid's name but
the kids daily activities knows you go
to which school who your friends are it
can actually be telling a story and
talking almost like a good friend the
kids can actually talk to the toy and
the toy can actually give them a
response
I think this is a a very bad idea you'll
be shocked to hear
that I who have rather skeptical of
technological progress and progress
generally I think this is probably a bad
idea
this technology
is designed to
alleviate loneliness
that's the idea of it
because even if you're isolated there
are a lot of lonely people out there
especially in this day and age there are
a lot of people who don't have a lot of
friends maybe they don't feel like they
have any friends in real life and
what they will try to do is turn to
technology to alleviate that loneliness
and so this sort of Technology the the
industry is talking about implementing
it into retirement homes into Hospice
Care into little kids bedrooms where
they're sitting alone at night and now
Mommy and Daddy don't need to read a
story to the kid the teddy bear is just
going to read the story to the kid and
that's going to make the kid feel like
he's talking almost like to a good
friend but
all of the evidence that we have is that
the result is really the opposite
that as technology becomes more
personalized as the media and the
technology become more social people
feel more alienated and more isolated
and the reason for that is we know
that it's just a computer we can tell
the difference between a person and a
computer and I think even if Chachi BT
and AI gets to the point where it is
almost indistinguishable from a human
being we're still going to know we still
know at a deep level the difference
between reality and simulation
we can watch
a conversation on a YouTube video and
that's great and it might pass the time
but it's not really going to make us
feel less lonely
it's not not really going to alleviate
that at all
and and the more that we rely on these
Technologies the the more alienated we
become I mean I've talked to people with
a whole host of Social pathologies and
different conditions
a notable one a notable one of those
conditions we're not allowed to talk
about on YouTube but I think I think we
know which issue we're talking about
here and they will say that they've
fallen into some of these pathologies
because of Technology because they go on
to Tumblr they go on to various social
media networks and they get lost in this
network of virtual friends but they're
not really friends and so all of the
insecurities remain and they just become
exacerbated and they fall further and
further into
fantasy and away from reality not not a
good thing not a good thing for the kids
just read your kid a story you lazy
parent don't don't put a robot teddy
bear in their crib what's wrong with you
we got to talk to each other in real
life with our real voices and when you
want to talk with your real voice to
your friends you got to check out pure
talk right now go to puretalk.com Noel's
a company that I'm proud to stand behind
because it's got a great product and
they're proud to stand behind us and our
country Pure Talk veteran owned with a
100 American Workforce they share our
beliefs that is why Pure Talk is the
official cell phone wireless partner of
the daily wire it's not the only reason
Pure Talk also happens to be the most
Dependable 5G Network in the U.S top
tier provider at a fraction of the cost
of those other woke companies that don't
care about you or your beliefs mix and
match your plans to fit every person in
your family choose from talk text 5G
data for just 20 bucks a month all the
way up to unlimited data with a mobile
hotspot for 55 a month you vote with how
you spend your money so stop supporting
woke wireless companies that don't
support you instead go to puretalk.com
adults you will get great coverage and
save while you're doing it when you go
to puretalk.com Knowles you will save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you
puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans
when Dr Jordan B Peterson made the
decision to join daily wire plus it was
a major win for those who Champion free
speech and intellectual debate with one
year of unparalleled output his
contributions have set new standards and
remain unmatched by any other platform
daily wire plus offers hundreds of hours
of exclusive Jordan content you won't
find anywhere else these include vision
and Destiny marriage Dragons monsters
and men Additionally you can immerse
yourself in discussions that nurture
your spiritual side such as logos and
literacy and Jordan's groundbreaking
series on the book of Exodus that is
only the beginning I haven't even
mentioned his Beyond order lecture
series or his extensive Archive of
lectures and podcasts plus there's even
more new exclusive content on the
Horizon by becoming a daily wire plus
member you will embark on an
unforgettable experience that will fuel
your thirst for knowledge and Inspire
personal growth like never before go to
dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member today my
favorite comment yesterday is from the
drummers Workshop Norms music
I I absolutely love that commenter that
commenter has popped up a lot in the
show and the comment is to quote Joe
Biden's dad
Joey it's simple they're coming for your
children very simple they are they are
in fact coming for your children
speaking of kids
speaking of the youths
Disney has cast its first transgender
actor in a major role
[Music]
speaking of legal issues
Justice samuelito
one of the greats on the Supreme Court
possibly my very favorite Justice on the
Supreme Court
certainly right up there with Lawrence
Thomas and I think probably even I agree
with Alito a little more than I agree
with Thomas
Sam Alito has a big Target on his back
and the lips are going after him so
there's a hack liberal
journalistic Outlet called propublica
which is trying to attack Sam Alito
and June up a scandal where there is
none and that's no surprise
the libs have been doing this for years
they've done it to Brett Kavanaugh
they've especially done it to Justice
Thomas
now they're doing it to Sam Alito what's
different here
when when they've done it to
conservative judges in the past that
conservative judges have have gone on
defense
so Brett Kavanaugh mounted that's very
strong defense in his confirmation
hearings you know I like beer I still
like beer or that whole thing and it
worked and I felt did a pretty good job
of dispelling the
silly nonsense the obviously concocted
nonsense of that woman Christine blasey
Ford where there's no evidence that you
ever even met Brett Kavanaugh you saw
this with Justice Thomas in the high
tech lynching confirmation hearings
where Thomas mance's defense he says
this is this is a National Disgrace this
is a circus this is a high-tech lynching
for uppity black so in any way Dame to
think for themselves and Joe Biden who
was chairing that meeting immediately
put his head down he thought oh no wait
I can't I look bad now that we're going
after Thomas
in this case though Alito is going on
the offense
Sam Alito published an op-ed a few days
ago in the Wall Street Journal
and says propublica misleads its readers
the publication levels false charges
about Supreme Court recusal Financial
disclosures and in 2008 fishing trip now
the the issue at play here is that some
guy invited Sam Alito to
fly on his private airplane to a place
that they were both going to and
this guy through some indirect means had
business before the court at some point
and so they're saying this is awful and
a leader should have recused himself and
this is corruption whatever and Alito
does a very good job of knocking this
down he says first of all this issue has
come before the court many times long
before I ever flew in this airplane and
I
My Views haven't really changed on it
and I was invited on this airplane this
was an empty seat it didn't it didn't
incur any extra cost for the guy who did
it to me and uh I I've been totally
above board in all my financial
disclosures and he just he just totally
knocks it down takes the wind out of the
sails the lesson here for conservatives
though
is that this unusual action of going on
offense even before an attack comes out
this needs to become the norm okay we
used to
let things lie a little bit not try to
get too aggressive try to maintain an
above it all sort of approach that's not
going to work any semblance of
neutrality in the public institutions
that's gone you're either you're either
with us or against us you know that's
the place that we're at now I'm not sure
if that was always the case or and and
we're just seeing it more clearly now or
if this is a real change to our
political order but whatever it is
we're now engaged in a fairly clearly
defined battle and this laissez-faire
you do you I don't have an opinion
procedural procedurism proceduralism
that has defined our politics for a long
time
that's over
pick a side fight very hard we've got a
guy
coming up who knows a thing or two about
that I'll be my friend Jesse Kelly the
rest of the show continues now in member
block you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Noel scanner to be well
asked to check out for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
um